I wanted the gig to present this yes to
present this year's Music Awards a
winner of the Jean Hersholt Humanitarian
Award and produced of tonight's
broadcast Quincy Jones
with Best Actress nominee the Sharon
Stone
there's a lot of great music being
composed for film these days but look
who I'm telling that to you don't think
Whoopi was right I got a little Colin
Powell thing going yeah thank you so
much so thank you you're right turn I
like to chill I like to slip a little
soundtrack into the CD player and relive
the movie sounds like a man who knows a
little something about scoring you got
it this year to increase the playing
field so to speak the Academy has
expanded the award for best film score
into two categories original musical
score or comedy score and Original
dramatic score in the first category
original musical or comedy score the
nominees are for the American president
Marc Shaiman
for Pocahontas Alan Menken music and
orchestral score and Stephen Schwartz
lyrics for Sabrina John Williams for Toy
Story Randy Newman for unstrung heroes
Thomas Newman and the Oscar for Best
Original musical a comedy score goes to
Alan Menken musical and orchestral score
and Stephen Schwartz merciful
well a lot of time and effort and
collaboration went into the scoring of
to a score of Pocahontas and I have a
lot of people to thank and not a lot of
time to thank them so I want to thank my
music team my Orchestrator Danny troub
synth arranger Martin Erskine my music
editor Cathy Bennet engineer John
Richards my thanks to Chris Montana Todd
Cooper our directors Mike Gabriel and
eric goldberg our producer Jim Pentecost
my Disney family past and present time
doesn't permit me to say all their names
but I particularly want to thank Peter
Schneider and Tom Schumacher and all the
brilliant singers musicians and
technicians whose talents made
Pocahontas sing and Thank You Academy
members
jaren oh honey
before we award another statue let's ask
the audience to join us and giving it up
for some of the best musicians on this
planet the Academy orchestra and musical
director Tom Scott
Quincy mm-hmm as hot as these musicians
are so too are the oscar-winning scores
that help define the character plot and
emotion of the film's they enhanced the
nominees for Best Original dramatic
score are for Apollo 13 James Horner for
Braveheart James Horner but Nixon John T
Williams for the postman he'll post you
know Luis Enrique baccala the Simpson
sensibility Patrick Doyle I don't have
the envelope so I'd like us all to have
a psychic moment
let's just concentrate it's coming to me
oh you can do better than that
oh my god it's ilpo steed oh good good
forgive me my English I feel thirty
years doing what I love it is completely
delightful to receive this connection
the people I would like to thank Michael
Rafa who directed in Postino with
mastery and love the writer Antonio
skeleton and all the people who do the
screenplay the producers Gaetano Daniele
and Vittorio chica gory my friends at
Miramax and my family this movie was
made because of the passion of math
symmetry see a wonderful man and a great
actor and I dedicate this a word to him
grazie tante